Here's a simple Android app using
street view to show a scene.
As I move my finger around the display,
you can see that I can
look around this location.
As I touch the arrows, you can see
that I can walk along the trail.
Similarly, if I touch in the far
distance, I can jump to that location.
This location is a hiking
trail in the Grand Canyon.
And as you can see, street view
isn't limited to just streets.
As I touch in the direction of the hike,
I simply follow the path.
This one actually goes all the way down
to the bottom of the Grand Canyon.
This virtual hike down
the Grand Canyon was built
using only a few lines of code.
Let's take a look at how to
build this for ourselves.